[Musique]
même si aujourd'hui je ne suis plus le
même homme cela n'effacera pas la
violence que je vous ai fait super
[Musique]
non
11 15 montardon pierre à 53 ans à
l'époque membre skinheads néonazis
il a battu des noirs et les homosexuels
mais un long séjour en prison
et surtout les images du séisme de 2010
en haïti ont carrément changé sa vie une
strie ainsi ainsi au tessin - tiens
merci tout le monde est devenu
aujourd'hui il veut changer les choses
voir je pense que je peux être la preuve
que c'est possible si un lieu qui écoute
ça fait pas mal changé l'histoire de
pierre
c'est une histoire de rédemption qu'il
partage avec d'autres ils se surnomment
les repentis ils racontent leur histoire
dans une bd
parmi eux et lisa à dégaine une ex
néonazis qui croyait à l'époque
simplement défendre certaines traditions
ce qu'est aujourd'hui ouvertement
lesbienne elle est aussi juive un virage
à 180 degrés ça permet
je pense de croire une deuxième chance
des témoignages qui doivent susciter la
discussion dont les salles de classe le
jeune qui veut comprendre pourquoi les
migrations et des gentils danger au
québec mais il faut descriptif ce soit
avec les députés
on a besoin d'immigration pourquoi voilà
et cetera des discussions est
essentielle dans le contexte actuel
selon les dernières données de
statistique canada les crimes haineux
ont augmenté de 21% au québec ici
sébastien desrosiers radio canada
montréal